this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by honey liquid iv
helix upstart and expressvpn more on
that later
let's get into the do the honeydew with
ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we
are over here
doing it in the night pants studios i'm
ryan sickler ryan sickler.com
ryan sickler on all social media look i
say it every week and i mean it every
week thank you for your support
thank you for helping the show people
ask what can we do what can we do
look the best thing to do is to engage
with the sponsors support the sponsors
that's what you can do all right there's
a lot of free ways to help the show tell
people about it all that good stuff you
guys are great make sure you're
subscribed to the youtube
channel um audio monday video every
tuesday
make sure if you're subscribed to the
patreon show it's growing
guys i i do the show called the honeydew
with y'all where i highlight the
lowlights
with y'all and uh we have heard
some [ __ ] stories it's y'all
delivering that's for damn sure it's
five bucks a month there's no tears no
levels none of that [ __ ] it's
it's five bucks a month it's 60 bucks a
year i know that's a lot of money for
some people i get it it's a it's a
utility bill it's a whatever but if
you're looking for more
content that's where you can get it
also uh if you or someone you know has a
story you think that needs to be heard
email me at honeydewpodcast gmail.com
hopefully we can do an episode with you
all right
honeydewpodcast.com that's the website
get your merch thank you for supporting
night pants nation y'all out there
looking good looking comfy
uh and i record here at the santa monica
music center so
whether you live in la or not you can
absolutely still get online music
lessons here
at the santa monica music center go to
santa monica music dot com use the code
honeydew they'll waive the registration
fee and give you a free lesson when you
sign
up for a package now that's all the biz
uh and you know we do i say all the time
we highlight the low lights
and uh these are the stories behind the
storytellers and it is a pleasure
to have this storyteller here today
first time here on the honeydew ladies
and gentlemen welcome hannah dickinson
everybody oh
thank you welcome welcome welcome
welcome
um first of all thank you for being here
thanks for having me you got it i
um i met you on so you have an epic
special which we're going to talk about
coming out
um i produced on it and i got to sit and
interview
i mean it was supposed to be 20 20
comedians eric abrams but it was upwards
of like probably 30.
so are they gonna cut some of us no
nobody's getting cut they're adding you
in that's why they kept adding people
um but congrats on that by the way
thank you but i got to do pre-interviews
with everyone and then i got to sit down
on set with everyone and basically do
what we're going to do today with all of
you guys
and your you just made me laugh so
[ __ ] hard you're just
one of those people that gets it and i
was like yes what a refreshing take on
everything shitty so thank you for being
here
i'm very excited to talk to you today
but before we get into it
in addition to your special that's
coming or maybe out at this point
we're not sure yet because we're
recording ahead but everything you want
to promote please
i have a podcast called don't tell mom
where i kind of just
talk about [ __ ] because i started it
when i was living in my mom's basement
when we started quarantine
and i was like texting with this guy and
i was in miami right before we hit
quarantine and uh
i texted him i've been drinking because
i don't drink
but i drank in miami because we're in
miami and um
i texted this guy who i had never met
before like hey thinking i was texting
my brother because that's how drunk i
was i go don't tell mom
and the guy was like aren't you 28.
i was like yeah that was the end of that
one but so i was like oh i should just
make that a podcast just talk about [ __ ]
that
you know my mom doesn't want to hear and
i seem to i seem to fall into
bad not bad situation i don't know
you've got that knack
there's no doubt like sitting and
talking to you i would have to agree
with you that you
stumble and you you do step in some dog
[ __ ]
yeah you do it's incredible my friend
was like do you think you do comedy
because
[ __ ] happens to you or do you think you
make [ __ ] happen to you because you do
comedy and i'm like i don't know
because it's all i feel like always like
weird [ __ ] happens
but maybe i'm also all right
before we get into what i wanted to talk
to you about right off the top
what's some of the stuff from your
podcast like don't tell mom the [ __ ]
that your mom
like would just die if she heard or knew
what's the craziest thing on there
well i took a lot of my guests have
crazy stories because they've been to
rehab and stuff i've never been to rehab
but that's only because i can't afford
it
um it's like
you know we look down it's just like a
private school you know what i mean
i can't afford it uh i also don't you
know i'm fine i just
uh i don't know i got like a matching
tattoo on a first date that says s
m on the first date
on the first date where i have a bathing
suit on i don't know if this is
appropriate
[Laughter]
and he got in the same spot yeah
of course magic tattoo in the matching
location yeah
and his boobs are bigger than mine i
will say that so
on the first date we're actually still
friends which is interesting
but uh and then i i
when i moved to la when i was in college
i i thought i was gonna do a playboy
mansion i thought i was gonna be like a
hostess i thought i was invited
but it turned out to be a scam and i was
just in like the valley and like a
two-story house with
a bunch of persian dudes it just got
really weird wait what
i like replied to a casting thing to be
like a host at the
at the mansion and it was by a playboy
casting guy so i thought i was going to
the mansion
yeah but i just ended up in like a
single family home in the valley with a
bunch of persian dudes
they were all taking drugs did you have
to get a rancher
it was like and this is before uber so
my friend dropped me off and i was like
by yourself you didn't even take a
friend no i did take a friend and she
was so mad at me um right so what
happens you walk in
listen this is what we're gonna do [ __ ]
it you and i are just you're just gonna
go
what's rifle one after the other because
you we don't have to go into linear
life story you're originally from where
virginia
all right virginia that's what it was
virginia i remember but i also
i spent time my parents i grew up a
little bit in new orleans and i feel
like
that sounds better yeah okay
it sounds more it makes more sense
because my life is chaotic it's not
chaotic i don't know it is a little
chaotic it is a little it's a little
okay
yeah all right so you are now dropped
off at
what you're expecting to go to the
playboy mansion but you're in the valley
where in the valley do you remember
like pouring deep i don't know
chatsworth out there
yeah yeah it was like not good
and you went in well because my friend
dropped us off and i was like oh maybe
they're gonna
take us we did so it was like party at
the supper club after party at the
mansion and this is where we're meeting
so i'm thinking
this is the pre-game this is the
pre-game but i get there and it's like
girls who are like
questionably 18. you know what i mean oh
really
yeah how old were you at the time uh 19.
okay
um yeah it was definitely like a sex
trafficking sich
what it felt like it there were girls in
like victoria's secret pink underwear
which is like the teen version you know
what i mean it's like
i was in a dress but there was one girl
who's in
this like get up lingerie and she had
she it was all these buckles and then
she like didn't fully wipe her butt so
it was just like it was insane what are
you talking about
what do you mean what do you might talk
about she didn't fully wipe her butt
she had poop on her butt on it yes
it was just like on her but she walked
by it it's on her ass
yes and she's wearing a full white get
up i'm like how did you get
every buckle intact and you couldn't
fully wipe your ass
that might be the tactic for keeping
people away from you in a situation like
that
i mean wipe [ __ ] on yourself i i
i yeah so how many what's the ratio of
men to women and
male 2 let's not even say women because
you said questions yeah there was like
girls between the ages of like
16 to 58.
like it was like insane there was like
58.
it was crazy it was like older women who
it was just
it was and they're just walking around
in lingerie
and doing what is there music going is
there music going on there were
warm handles of vodka smearing off warm
oh yeah
that hot ass balance yeah it was like
gross
i mean i still had a cocktail but i'm
like shitty on it like i still did
uh drink from it and that's how i knew
it was warm but
there they had like baggies of like
powder that people were doing they were
dancing with these guys they were like
sitting on their laps these guys were
wearing silk shirts and they're like
sweating through their shirts
and i'm there thinking i don't even know
why i thought like going to a playboy
mansion would be
exciting i guess it was just because it
was i hadn't done anything i didn't know
what i wanted to do i hadn't started
stand up yet
so i was like oh i want to be in the la
scene so i
i thought going to playboy mansion i was
like am i going to be hugh hefner's like
girlfriend
which is insane that
that's how confident i was at the time
nothing wrong with that confidence yeah
and then i started standing up comedy
and just
yeah let me bring it back down there
yeah let me just
yeah that was uh that's very humble
because i had recently lost like 25
pounds so i was like really like oh i'm
a model and um i'm
not and so i so we ended up like getting
in these limos
that were like truly town cars so how
many men do you think were running this
thing that night ten
five not a lot ten how many women you
think
like 40. god damn yeah all in one house
all in one house and now you're getting
in limos this is
crazy [ __ ] right here yeah so you still
get in the limo
because i was like how the [ __ ] are we
gonna get back we didn't have uber or
anything and i wasn't about to lose my
pride and call my friend to pick us back
i'd rather lose your life guys i was
like i would rather
die than have my friend think i'm not a
[ __ ] playboy bunny
i was like i'm gonna i am hot all right
so first like this sounds like a scam
and i was like
why because i'm because i can't be a
playboy but like i was like why why is
it a scam because i'm not hot enough and
um she was absolutely correct
i love that you can admit it yeah it was
just like
looking back and then should we get in
limo and they're like okay we're going
to the mansion
so i'm like oh we're going to stop at
the mansion before the supper club and
this was a house in the hills
which also the mansion is in beverly
hills it's it's better off of beverly
glen i just rode by it the other day
i've been to it twice i've been to it
twice
well relax i've been to it
yeah i didn't even look it up that's how
dumb i am i'd even look it up
where it was beforehand so we're in the
hollywood hills and it's another big
house
and these girls are like so now you go
from the valley up to the hills
and you're in a limo with how many
people probably like
15. so they're probably three three
limos yeah
and it's like a couple guys and all
these ladies of different where's the
girl with the [ __ ] on her hope she's not
in your car
she was not me yeah obviously i was like
i'm not taking her
i'm not sharing a seat with that girl so
i was like
yeah so i get in this other limo
and this guy puts his arm around me and
he's wearing a gray silk shirt and he
just has like sweat stains right here
under his titties right where his s m
tat would go yeah right exactly
right that's where yeah it was actually
that guy we ended up going on a date
no he puts his arm around me and i'm
like
like i don't know what to do right
because i don't want to i don't know if
they're carrying weapons like at this
point i don't know
i don't want to piss them off but like i
also don't want to be touched by this
like
dude and he offers me a like a little
literal like ziploc baggie of like
powder
and i'm like and you don't know if it's
coke or whatever yeah and i'm not like a
drug person
i just they freak me out bad anxiety so
it's just not worth it
um so i didn't do that but then we got
out
going to this new mansion and my friend
i hid in a bush
outside the house and for probably an
hour while our other friend came picked
us up
nah yeah so good you didn't go in there
no because i was like watching these
girls and they're like in heels like
trying to walk up this hill and i'm like
these girls are gonna [ __ ]
die or you know and it felt
scary but they were still on board that
was the craziest part like me and my
friend were the only people who were
like
like this is like not this is crazy
but these girls really thought it was a
playboy thing or
i think they were just like like to
party you know i
i think they were like oh we're with
these guys who have a lot of money
and that's cool and that
is i yeah i
i went to usc so i was like i've been in
enough sketchy situations with guys who
like
have a lot of money where i know this is
just not going to be cool
also the they had smirnoff i'm like
obviously they don't have that much
money
they're not like rocking gray goose or
like anything like that
and also the limos were like
not these are dachshunds man what the
[ __ ]
yeah i i mean i sound stuck up but i was
just thinking in my head like
it this is just so it felt like
it's typical la story of someone who
moves to la and they're like wait
i guess this is a porno like you're like
just suddenly doing anal
you know it's like how did i get here so
i
i was like we need to get out of here my
friend's like i'm in business school
hannah she kept saying that hannah i'm
in business school and i was like
sorry like maybe you should have like
assessed the risks or whatever business
people do so whatever
business yeah i was like why are you mad
at me you agreed to come to this [ __ ]
and she was like you told me this was a
playboy party i was like
i i don't know so yeah that was
a crazy yeah that was a wild experience
but i luckily like you know we caught on
immediately but
i also felt so dumb because i like told
my friends you know like i'm going to
playboy party
then you had to go back and tell them
yeah well i just told them that i got
sick and didn't go
obviously i wasn't about to tell them
that i got my hair blown out for that
which i did
uh got my hair blown out i didn't eat
for two days like i was on a juice
cleanse
i got my nails done i got my [ __ ] wax i
was like fully ready
to get the [ __ ] in i was like i'm gonna
be a [ __ ] girlfriend
watch out i was like i like left like oh
my god like
i'm about to be on tv like i'm about to
be hugh hefner's girlfriend
like do i like not sign a lease on my
apartment if i'm gonna move into the
mansion like i fully had this thought
is that always something you wanted to
do no i just
like attention i think and just and
would you have been okay with being one
of the
like 10 girls or whatever it is of hugh
hefner's girlfriend i'm always one of
the 10
so at least this i'm a side bit
sure yeah i'm literally wearing side
pictures like i don't
i'm not i've never like won the one i'm
always
the one of ten so yeah i think i would
have been chill with it in that house by
a pool at least he owns a pool
why did you go i uh one lady
in the building i lived with worked with
him and was like took care of his
animals and i called her on her [ __ ]
and i was like you don't work there
she's like come tomorrow and i went and
i got in and another time was just a
friend
his sister was like bismarck's business
manager or some [ __ ] and he was dj in
the party and we went there
i got in twice yeah wow i wish i'd known
you then i would have told you it
it ain't where they're taking you that's
drew hefner over there yeah exactly
that's a [ __ ] mansion up in the
hills but it was yeah it was just a
weird
they probably rented you know probably
not theirs
it sounds like everything's like a night
they probably didn't even rent fully
right it was they probably pulled their
money together to get three limos
cheap alcohol and a mansion and then
tell a bunch of ladies this is some
playboy [ __ ] and get you all up there
and see what they can get
you're 100 right yeah i think he was
like
no i already sounded i was like i think
he was a legitimate casting director
uh because he had he had the logo and
his
but you can get that off google i don't
know why off of google yeah i'm not
i don't know why i'm like trying to
defend this guy like suddenly
but yeah that was one of and i don't do
that
i think it was just like i don't know
why i did it to be honest
every step of the way sounds terrifying
to me
every step of the way for sure and i
i but i was also you know 19 i thought
it was really cool
and i just wanted to go to the playboy
mansion and i think
just check it out and take photos you
know it by
the you know whatever the what does he
call it the grotto
yeah the grotto yeah so i was like fully
excited to do that and then
it just turned south so quick and i was
like oh god
but i got it i did i was like
who knows who you're gonna meet you
never know and always be prepared
and uh you all watch yeah
it was like oh
you're too much you really do make me
laugh let's take a quick break and tell
you about our first sponsor helix now i
recently got a helix mattress i put the
bed together with my daughter
we put the mattress on i made it a whole
thing with her got her queen bed told
her she'd be queen of the room
and we're gonna start sleeping in our
own bed more and more you know what i'm
saying
and uh if you're a parent you do and i'm
telling you it is so comfortable it's
big enough for me
it's comfortable i had a great night's
sleep i haven't been sleeping great how
many you've been sleeping great during a
worldwide pandemic this mattress
is awesome and the great thing about it
is they have this sleep quiz okay it
just takes two minutes to complete and
it matches your body type and your sleep
preference
to the mattress for you right so
everybody's unique and helix knows that
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium and firm mattresses
mattresses for great for cooling you
down if you sleep hot and even a helix
plus mattress for plus size folks
now i took the helix quiz and i was
matched with the midnight lux mattress
because i wanted something that was like
a medium firm
i tend to sleep on my side um and it's
been great i've had other
mattresses delivered to me um and they
have not lived up to what this
helix mattress is not even close i'm
telling you right now
so if you're looking for a mattress you
take the quiz you order the mattress
that you're matched to and the mattress
comes right to your door shipped for
free you don't ever need to go to a
mattress store again
helix is awesome but you don't need to
take my word for it helix was awarded
the number one best overall mattress
pick of 2020 and by
gq and wire magazine so go to
helixsleep.com
honeydew take their two-minute sleep
quiz they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life
they have a 10-year warranty and you get
to try it out for a hundred nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you
if you don't love it but you will
alright so right now helix is offering
up to 200
off all mattresses and two free pillows
for my listeners go to helixsleep.com
that's h-e-l-i-x-s-l-e-e-p
dot com honeydew one more time helix
sleep.com
honeydew our next sponsor is liquid iv
now the weather's changing people are
getting cold you're bundling up more
and cooler weather makes it easier to
miss signs of dehydration like
overheating or perspiration which means
it's even more important
to keep your body properly hydrated with
one stick of liquid iv
in 16 ounces of water you get two to
three times the amount
of hydration as plain water they sent me
some i tried it out i had three flavors
my favorite's watermelon i put it in you
know
you can use it whenever you want whether
it's after a workout uh
when you're getting up long rope
whatever i use it in the middle of the
day i'm feeling just dehydrated
i just popped that in some water and
it's so good the watermelon was great
and flu season right now is
often lines up with holiday plants but
liquid iv can help support your immune
system
with increased hydration and essential
vitamins it's perfect for staying
hydrated on holiday flights like i said
long road trips
it can even help with hangovers after
those extra holiday drinks you know what
i'm saying
liquid iv's best-selling hydration
multiplier now has three new flavors
guava watermelon which i just told you i
loved and apple
pie i use it every day i've been using
them they're just a little powder pack
you just put it in your water
boom off you go put it in your thermos
whatever take it with you
stay hydrated all day okay one serving
of liquid iv
provides the same hydration as drinking
two to three bottles of water alone
three delicious new flavors contains
five essential vitamins it has way more
vitamin c than an orange and it has as
much potassium as a banana
it's healthier than sugary sports drinks
there's no artificial flavors or
preservatives and less sugar than an
apple
it's made with clean ingredients it's
non-gmo it's vegan
it's free of gluten dairy and soy what
makes liquid iv so effective
it's cellular transport technology they
call that ctt y'all the optimal ratio of
glucose sodium and potassium delivers
water and nutrients
into the bloodstream it's the perfect
balance to help you hydrate more quickly
and effectively
than water alone liquid iv is on a
mission to change the world the company
has donated over 5 million servings
globally in response to coven 19
products are being donated to hospitals
first responders food banks
veterans active us military there's over
3 million servings
in total so far liquid iv is available
nationwide at walmart
in the beverage section or you can get
25
off when you go to liquidive.com and use
code honeydew at checkout that's 25
off of anything you order when you use
the promo code honeydew
at liquidive.com get better hydration
today
at liquidity.com promo code honeydew
stay hydrated y'all our next sponsor is
expressvpn i've been telling you i've
been watching a lot of shows during this
uh
this quarantine and i don't know if you
guys have seen the social dilemma but
man you gotta check out the social
dilemma that's a great movie
uh makes me wanna stop using social
media to be honest with you but i can't
because i have to tell you guys where to
find me and what to watch and all that
stuff so
uh i don't know if you've seen it but
you should in the documentary tech
insiders explain how social media is
engineered to exploit users data for
profit they call it surveillance
capitalism
and i'm cool with normal capitalism
where i'm a willing participant in the
transaction like every time i go to the
store to buy food but when my date is
being harvested so tech billionaires can
get even richer
that's where we need to draw the line
and that's why i put a layer of
protection around my data with
expressvpn every time you use the
internet big tech companies are mining
your data by tracking your searches
messages video history when you run
expressvpn on your device it hides your
ip address which websites can use to
personally identify you that makes your
activity more difficult to trace
and sell to advertisers now you still
need to be careful with what you share
on social media but expressvpn
can make your web browsing more
anonymous all right the
expressvpn also encrypts 100 of your
internet data to keep you safe from
hackers and prying eyes
and many vpns slow down your internet
but not expressvpn it's incredibly fast
and easy to use you just tap one button
and you're protected so if you don't
like the idea of tech companies
exploiting your personal information
then visit expressvpn.com honeydew right
now
and you can get three extra months of
expressvpn for free that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot slash honeydew to protect your data
expressvpn.com
honeydew to learn more now let's get
back to the do
um all right let's talk about what we
talked about
on set there about what happened to you
recently because i
really your take on this and your
attitude toward it i think is
very healthy oh the herpes what a
transition
what a transition i was trying to go
gentle
yeah it's like uh i tell that story that
i'm like i have burpees
and also you do have a library of
stories so in your defense you're like
you might not know what the [ __ ] i was
talking about no i knew it was the
herpes
tell me about let's talk about this yeah
i just um
i was
the thing you met a guy right yeah i met
a guy and we were dating
before quarantine so this is a thing
i lied obviously i love getting the reel
well because i just like my i was seeing
him in dc
when quarantine first started it was
like at the beginning
and my parents like didn't care i was
like
going to see someone like they knew i
was kind of but i didn't want them
to i guess whatever um i
i just we were seeing each other very
i just didn't want i guess i didn't want
to seem like i was seeing someone in
quarantine
which i was but also it was like we were
just seeing each other it wasn't like we
were going you know what i mean
i wasn't going out to big parties but we
were just seeing each other and i was
dating him all living in my parents
basement so it was just like this weird
experience in my
so where so where were you right before
a quarantine hit
i was in new york okay and then you
decided to go to your parents because
new york got
it was bad right yeah and my parents
were like please come here like we don't
want you in new york so then i i
quarantined fully for two weeks and
did that and then i started seeing this
person
how did you meet him just online yeah
just online um and then
yeah we like we're hanging out
and it's funny because i talked to my
therapist
and i was like yeah he's so nice like he
was such a nice guy
and he is a nice guy i just think he's
actually stupid but
i he was so nice and he was like i like
you and i've never had someone
before be so open about how they felt
about me like he was like
he went home he's like i watched all
your stand up like i i he was
very like interested in my career which
sounds very pathetic that i'm like isn't
that crazy
uh but it felt very different than what
i've experienced of guys treating me
like dog [ __ ]
and then one night we didn't have a
condom
and i was like when was the last time
you were tested and he told me
he got tested he recently got tested and
he hadn't seen anyone
because of quarantine because this was
probably like a month in a month and a
half in
and i was like oh okay and i believed
him because he was such a nice guy
but he also didn't say what the results
he just said i got tested he didn't say
he was like he was like i got tests i
don't have anything okay and then i
haven't seen anyone
and then i was like okay great
and because he had been such a nice guy
i was
i believed him you know like it didn't
and so we hooked up and then
he went out of town for like four days
and i got really really sick because
with herpes you get sick you get a virus
and what kind of sick are you like fever
and all that
so do you think it's corona i think it's
corona
this is why it's so different when we
talked about it before yeah because now
you're thinking you got coronav
yeah and i just like didn't want people
to be like i don't know i guess it
now i'm saying it but i just felt like
adding that element to the
i don't know i don't know why i lied i
guess i was just nervous what people
would say
um but here i am but you get a virus
yeah so i get a virus and
my parents just stopped the corona just
that crow i'm like how did
i literally caught the wrong virus i was
like how is chronology not the wrong
fire how corona is so easy to catch ah
herpes baby that is like
so easy i was like i caught the wrong
virus so you get chronic tested i get
strep tested they're like no
like it's clear and i you go right i
mean you start feeling this right away
these symptoms are like
two days after two days and it was weird
like i remember
in my basement i felt like a weird like
illness like
shoot up my spine i'm like oh i feel
really sick and then i'm like
oh my god i'm like it just like hit me
it literally like hit me and i was like
oh my god
i need to lie down and then i i go to
lie down and
so for a week i can't get out of bed
and and how quickly do you go get tested
so
this is another element to it i really
bad eczema like all over my body
so i get bad eczema in my butt crack is
this
inappropriate it's it's you girl so i
didn't like
it hurt when i took a [ __ ] sorry
but i was like oh my eczema's getting so
bad and i didn't look because i couldn't
get out of bed so i was just not eating
so i wouldn't have to [ __ ] because it
hurt so bad
oh my god so i lost 10 pounds which like
silver body by herpes i've been like
spending so much i've been spending
thousands of dollars on soulcycle on
barry's bootcamp and then i catch herpes
and i'm like
all right well here we go i'm down 10
guys
yeah i'm like texting my coaches i'm
like don't worry week
don't worry i lost somebody so i can't
get out of bed and so i text him
i start texting this guy i'm like hey
i'm like really sick did you get
corona because this is like before i got
my chrono test he's like no that's so
weird
and then when my corona test was
negative i was like texting him i was
like hey are you sure
you don't have anything because like i'm
like very ill
so how quickly did your coronal results
come back four days it took four days
so and still you're still really ill
during that four days yeah like
extremely ill and he's not
he's like bedridden ill like bedridden
like i didn't leave bed for three days
like damn
yeah i slept like 20 hours a day like i
couldn't or maybe
15 18 hours a day i couldn't move i
didn't know this was
a part of it so it's not for guys really
it's mostly for women
so he didn't get hit with the flu like a
lot of people don't
it really depends so that i was like
okay and then i like
went to pee one day and i was like okay
that
that hurt so then i take a photo
of my vagina and i was like
well that is that's not good like that's
that's gotta be it looked like a [ __ ]
jackson pull off it was like [ __ ]
insane
it was insane and at this point it's
something crawling down my legs because
i hadn't looked what it's like down my
legs at this point
like like chicken pox okay i mean listen
i'm glad you said that because
i had a roommate and not to stop your
story but
he he got a prostitute he went to a
massage
parlor had sex with a prostitute swears
he used a condom
i still don't think he did definitely
did not and listen
the next day i'm telling you people are
like nah
the next morning now here's the other
thing i've thought
about maybe he had gone a week prior
also maybe it was that but i'm telling
you it was a sunday night
that monday morning and he's like can i
show you i'm like i don't want to see it
he's like it's not just let me show you
and he pulled up his shorts and it was
in like his groin like the skin and
coming down his leg a little bit and i
was like man you should go
here's my doctor go see him now and he
did and he had
he had it but it was it was like chicken
it looked like chicken pox like
red and but i didn't know it could just
get on your skin like that
yeah it does happen like literally the
next day yeah because
and he was sweaty and like he was sick
like you said i remember
but not bedridden for three days or so
may that's the difference i guess you
said it
it affects women differently yeah
i guess because so it's what do you mean
down your legs what do you do
i just start freaking out and i'm i'm
texting him and he was texting me
literally every day like three times a
day and then as soon as i tell him i'm
like starting to feel sick like his
texts
start like going away he stops kind of
responding and i'm getting so nervous
and finally i text him i was like i
think you gave me aids just
to get a response well just the hey
and he was like are you kidding me like
you think i gave you
aids and i was like well you gave me
something so
how about you start telling me the truth
and he doesn't respond and then i was
like okay i'm going to get tested this
morning
doesn't respond i get tested no response
to that no response
and then so i go to the doctor and she's
like
yeah that's herpes i'm also wearing this
shirt by the way like i didn't
swear to god because i had stayed up all
night i didn't sleep that night before
because i was looking at vaginas like
i'm a full-blown gynecologist at this
point
and so i wear a sweatshirt and i go to
the doctors and i take it off and she's
like yeah that's
herpes like i don't even need like to
get in there like i see it
and um she's like you have to get a
blood test to figure out
which type type one or type two wait you
got a herpes test
and a side [ __ ] t-shirt i wasn't aware
of what i was wearing
okay i wasn't aware i was just like so
tired i was so
and i don't have a lot of clothes i got
this shirt from miami i just wore it on
and then i'm like are you [ __ ]
kidding me
and i'm like so she tells me my burpees
and i just start bawling his main [ __ ]
probably got a two day you know
exactly
all ten of the side [ __ ] happened
literally i was like
yeah i actually got the shirt from him
too so she just was like
yeah yeah you got it yeah and of course
i start crying because it's like
you know devastating yeah and then
she was like honestly like i know it's
devastating but it is very like the
problem with herpes is like the mental
my like the stigma and how we treat it
as a society because it
it you get sick the first time but if
i'm now taking a medication every day so
i don't get another outbreak
and if i were to get another outbreak it
could be bad but i wouldn't feel sick so
you don't get
you build up antibodies so i don't know
i'm not defending the disease
i'm not trying to make it sound better
than it is but no but i like normalizing
it
more than you're right it is a stigma i
mean
i've had girls had to tell me they've
had it and
uh i'm fortunate i don't but they've had
to tell me
and then you know they also tell me they
know it you know what i mean they've had
it so
apparently they can feel it coming you
know you
you know when you're if you're going to
have an outbreak and
and then when you don't you know you use
protection and
you know you're both safe yeah because
you can't transfer unless you have an
outbreak but there is also a period
before
oh wait so you can have unprotected sex
as long as you're not having an outbreak
and it won't transfer i just thought it
had to do with
i'm an idiot i'm not a scientist or
anything i just thought fluids
and you can get it period no it's like
lesion contact
so it's like but there is a weak
shedding period before so you just have
to be really careful like i know a comic
who has it
i won't say who but they were telling me
like
it was like my wife and i have
unprotected sex all the time and like
he i she hasn't gotten it because you
just have to be really aware of
like your body and know when it's coming
or
he was like i haven't had an outbreak in
three years so we do have unprotected
sex because
you can't it's lesion once it's skin is
skin contact so it's like
so once someone's the outbreak is there
then you can just rub it against the
body and get it
yeah exactly so wait so then he did he
had an outbreak then when you had sex
with him
that's what's crazy is i
would have had to right yeah but i
didn't see it but i i didn't like also
like take a microscope out and look at
his dick and like also it could have
been under his dick like i don't really
know
but can people be asymptomatic to that
yes but then you can't transfer it if
you're asymptomatic oh
so cause like hpv i know they say guys
can have it
never have once not even know you have
it like i we could
all have it not even know we have it
exactly for guys
yeah exactly yeah and women too with hpv
it's like how do you
so you you said to me before we um
started recording that uh someone had
started a support group
yeah my friend who's a comic who's a
female i called
my friend like put us in because i was
very depressed for i'm still kind of sad
about it you know like
yeah i mean it's a you know you trusted
someone that you liked
who lied to you clearly and he had an
out so what i'm saying is from what i've
because i also have a friend a married
couple and the same thing
she has it he doesn't but she said i
know when they're coming i can feel them
i take medication the same thing he's
never got it they've been married for
10 years or whatever you know maybe
longer actually
um but if that's the case
then he knew he had it he must have
known
he had an outbreak he didn't know he had
now he claims
uh he says that he so when i was like
you need to be honest with me right now
because i told i threatened to get a
lawyer involved like i was
so pissed i was like i know you're
[ __ ] lying to me like stop
we like at this point i have it and if
you didn't have it before now you
definitely have it so like
just be honest like we need to figure
this out he was like okay like i
actually slept with like four girls or
whatever
right before you and i was like jesus
christ like
and i was like all unprotected and he
was like yeah and then he goes
and there's this one suspect sketchy
girl that i think gave it to me and i go
[ __ ] you dude like how did you knew yeah
he knew the girl and everything
and i was like but also like why are you
calling her suspect and sketchy now
we're [ __ ] suspect and
sketchy so don't call her that that
pissed me off too i was like
don't say that because you just did
now we're that person and i don't want
to be sketchy
and um so i just reamed him out and he
was like you got to go easy on me like i
just found out i got herpes too and i
was like you're such a [ __ ] loser
but you don't even know if that's true
he could have had this [ __ ] for 10 years
he's going to say he just got it you
don't know
now i see the way i am i don't believe
anything you're telling me now oh
yeah i just know you're a piece of [ __ ]
you gave it to me you knew you had an
outbreak and gave it to me
mm-hmm i was so i was so angry and so
depressed and then so
my friend was like because what i was
waiting for i've been here for a little
bit and she was like
oh like are you on bumble are you i'm
like no i'm not any of those [ __ ]
apps like
no it's gotten me nowhere except [ __ ]
herpes and like
also i'm in l.a for a month so i'm not
gonna start a relationship with someone
and i'm also not gonna like
have sex with anyone and she was like
i think you gotta talk to this one
comment because she has a tooth so she
like said an intro about how we should
hang out and talk because she has herpes
and my friend was like
nice intro like it's such a weird thing
to be like you guys should talk
um but she was like yeah i started the
support group you should join so i did
the zoom herpes support group oh hold on
i don't know why in my mind i thought
you all got together
no no we're you know we already have one
virus we don't need two
so we're not getting together we don't
imagine having a covet outbreak in a
herpes outbreak meeting
i got corona at the herpes meeting
she's like yeah i mean they are prone to
viruses so
why would you get together you [ __ ]
kill me
but it was so sad it was like i was like
uh
it's a zoom meeting for are these all
comedians or just this
group she put together it's all women uh
it was
all no it's co-ed but it was all women
and of course one dude i'm like yeah hot
guys don't get tested like of course
there's no guys in a herpes worker they
don't know they have herpes
they're just handing it out like how do
you think we got here like
and of course there's one girl in there
who's so hot she's like the hottest girl
i've ever seen in my life
she's like yeah i've actually never been
rejected when i told a guy at herpes and
i was like
obviously like you could have full blown
aids and guys would be
like double penetrating you like
but i was like why are you here uh but
she was the only like optimistic one
and another girl who the thing that made
me depressed was a girl who literally
looked like me
she was like a six and she she's
a long way down the hill you hefner's
girlfriend
yeah right i'm like i go from [ __ ]
one mansion to
a zoo a harpy zoo
i was like yeah this is from your
parents basement yeah even
oh no this is a full house with
cockroaches it's all just
a nightmare i'm like yeah i don't
i was so grossed out by a cockroach i
was so grossed out by the cockroaches
and then i was like
well you know i got [ __ ] herpes so um
but this one girl was like yeah she was
just saying that she
every sh the thing is to tell guys on
the fifth date i guess that's the
way to the fifth date why five because
you wanna like make sure they like you
and like um
you want to build a relationship with
someone before which i'm like that
sounds
exhausting like i'm not doing that um
so she said every time in the past year
she's told a guy on the fifth date
they've like
like not responded or like stopped
talking to her
and it made me so depressed because i
was just like oh [ __ ] like that sucks
that
yeah that does suck and it sucks too
because it's like
we're trying to be honest about it and
people are like uh when it's like a lot
of people do
have it and refuse to get tested one
because you can be asymptomatic and have
in your blood and you might [ __ ] have
it
so um if you don't get tested you don't
know because
a lot of doctors won't take i don't know
why i'm like i should have worn a lab
coat but
i a lot of doctors won't test your blood
for it because so many people have it
that they're like you're chasing a
positive basically what's that mean
it's like so many people have it that
like if it shows up on your blood then
you have to now
tell people you have to disclose this
information with your sexual partners
but if you don't like have an outbreak
you can't
give it to someone so they're like
there's no point of you going through
the mental gymnastics
of having of knowing oh so you mean if
you're asymptomatic
or carrier or whatever the [ __ ] it's
called you have it
but they're just saying like look you if
you don't have an outbreak or anything
what's the point
exactly so there's no point of you know
why because to in the medical yeah but
in the medical world
like i get it in their defense it's like
so they see it probably
12 times a day or more you know what i
mean so it's like what's the big deal
but to you
it's everything yeah exactly yeah it's
yes well that's why they're saying
they're not in a number exactly cause
they're like makes you a statistic
exactly and they're like you don't want
this to hap like people get so depressed
like there
there are [ __ ] support groups for it
so it's like people are
i've never heard of a herpes support
group yeah well
had you congrats
no because i didn't have [ __ ] herpes
so i was like going around looking for a
piece of paper nothing well it's funny
because like i've done aa too and it's
like
i was gonna say i'm not an alcoholic but
i know of a a and
n a and all these groups i i mean i
don't know why not i guess there would
be a support group for anything right
yeah yeah i guess it's just like but the
thing is with a you're talking about how
much your life got better
after you quit drinking with herpes it's
like by the way
you're not really like there's no real
upside you're not like
you know now this was a depressing zoom
call
yeah i guess i shouldn't [ __ ] on it
because it's like nice to hear and
everything
but um i didn't leave the group like
excited for the day i was like you
didn't want to go do commercials and
[ __ ]
yeah i wasn't like you know those are
the people thriving with herpes the ones
out there getting paid for it and doing
commercials
you know those [ __ ] probably don't
even have it they're riding horses i'm
like no you don't do that not with this
not with this ass crack yeah no no yeah
i was like
how are these people like so active i
was like i was
bedridden for i couldn't walk for like
two weeks
that should be the [ __ ] if that if
that was the commercial
probably people would be more careful
and it's like look at these people
having a great time with herpes
yeah it's just such a it feels so
because i do talk about sex in my stand
up and like
i'm you know i'm not afraid to make a
sexual joke and now it feels like uh
having herpes feels that's honestly the
hardest part because for me i'm like
honestly dating was not going well
anyway so it's like
if i don't i don't really care
talking about it because it only affects
people like
who are gonna have sex with me and i
don't feel like having sex with anyone
so
yeah and i mean i i just look i love
that you're breaking down the stigma i
love that you're
openly talking about this and being
comfortable i they're
who knows how many people listening or
seeing this have it i'm
tons probably it's so common
um but but you're right people are
embarrassed what's the what's
the hardest part for you like do you
feel like you
let yourself down like because you
trusted this dude or do you feel like
you got
you know swindled like what's the
hardest part of all or is it telling
your
your
next partner what is the hardest part i
think it's just that
yeah it kind of just feels like a dui
for the [ __ ] you know
i gotta take a break i gotta rethink my
choices
what am i doing here
we're like oh god this is going to come
up in court sometime you know
dui for the [ __ ] is it not
it's like a real bummer
that's following you everywhere oh man
that is
so good if you're not put that in your
[ __ ] stand up you better
you [ __ ] better and but that's how it
feels it's just like
uh like it's just embarrassing i think i
feel
embarrassed and i feel like i live you
know like
i don't have sex with more than most of
my friends or like the average person
but actually more than the average i
checked online the average person has
like
six or seven people okay in life
yeah now yeah right that's [ __ ] yeah
um
but i always say this too like let's say
you started at 16.
you lost your let's say you [ __ ] it
let's say you lost your virginity at 20
and you're 45 40 let's say 40 and you're
single
if you just slept with two people a year
i in my personal opinion i don't think
that's
[ __ ] or whatever but if over 20 years
and
times two that's 40 partners if you took
the number of partners people would say
oh well you were [ __ ] or you were this
and you were that and i think that if
it's done like that it's not
that's just not good at relationships
it's not that you're a [ __ ]
you're just you know or or loose or
whatever
you know a ladies whatever the [ __ ] they
go you know
term you want to use for it but i think
if you add it like that it's not
promiscuous or whatever you just you're
not good at dating or relationships
that's what i told my i try to make a
joke about this but i was like i have
way less sex like the number of times i
have sex is
way less than like my and relationships
i've had sex way less times but i've had
way more partners because it's just like
it doesn't work out yeah right i
like end up with douche bags so it's
like that
is something that but now it just feels
like
it's the shame that i'm trying i mean
i'm talking about it because i
i feel like i felt like i like i i
called the suicide hotline like i said i
was dude
so depressed whoa i didn't know you got
there yeah
and i always told her and she was like
ooh i'm like what
they said she was like oh like it was
like a weird like reaction i was like do
i have a right hand
cara i got one with herpes on the line
uh
we'll be right back with you she said uh
she was just like
yeah you know yeah
you just get that now yeah i did i was
like oh who are you telling me i have
herpes yeah my mom she already knows
mom carol
exactly right
but no we ended up talking about it for
a while i was just like so depressed i
was just like it feels like now i have
this
i'm like this different person and um
if it just feels like now i have i'm
like a
in a group of people it just i feel
so it felt so like i felt so gross like
i'm like now i'm this gross person
but i mean it it is
truly like a skin thing i mean it's in
your blood i guess it's more than that
but
it is like a you know i get eczema
that's horrible so it's like i do
already have like weird skin [ __ ]
and i think this will honestly probably
be better because people
now and when i tell a guy if he doesn't
want
to if he's not interested then he wasn't
interested in me
but there's also a damn good chance he's
relieved because he does too
exactly you know what i mean i mean the
numbers they're telling us about this
there's a damn good chance he does too
yeah thank god yeah
instead of i'm [ __ ] out of here or
whatever
you know yeah and so this feels like i
mean i'm just taking a time to like not
date and really just kind of figure out
you know just
do my work on i don't even i don't know
what i'm trying to say i'm like do me
uh which is like not a thing um but just
not
puts i feel like i was giving guys so
much credit and like so much trust and
so much of my time and i'm like
i don't need to do that anymore so it
honestly i don't want to say i feel
relieved because it's not relieved but
it's like
i just my mindset's so different it's
like i don't care anymore like you guys
are all
shits you guys are all bags of [ __ ] so
it's like
i don't need to put my time and energy
into this and this feels like a good
reason not to and i was very upset
and very and i'm lucky i didn't get
[ __ ] aids i'm truly lucky i didn't
get aids
you are lucky you are lucky
so there's worse things and
now it's like yeah it does suck that
there is more of a stigma on women than
men
but that's with everything so let's take
a quick break and tell you about our
next sponsor honey now these days it
feels like online shopping is the only
shopping we're really doing out there
that's where our sponsor today honey
comes in it's it's free okay check this
out it's a free browser extension
and it scours the internet for promo
codes and automatically applies the best
one available at checkout
honey is basically your online shopping
best friend now here's how it works
you get honey on your computer for free
in two easy clicks you're
by going to joinhoney.com honeydew okay
honey.com
honeydew then when you're checking out
on one of its over 30 000 supported
sites honey pops up and all you have to
do is click
apply coupons so if you're out there
shopping for birthday gifts you got the
holidays coming up it's a great time
right now especially on a budget
you put honey on your computer when
you're checking out it will
automatically apply you just have to
click that
uh button you wait a few seconds as
honey searches for coupons for that site
and if honey finds a working code it'll
apply the best one to your cart all
right
i've been using it lately they told me
to try it out it's awesome man
you go to check out buying some clothes
whatever it is and boom
there's a coupon boom i've saved over 50
bucks on a couple things
just by applying honey uh honey has
found
its over 17 million members over two
billion dollars in
savings okay honey supports all kinds of
retailers from tech and gaming sites to
fashion brands to even food delivery
so it's really simple if you have a
computer honey should be on it it's free
and it works with whatever browser you
use you can get honey for free today
at joinhoney.com honeydew that's
joinhoney.com honeydew
our next sponsor is upstart now you know
how i feel about upstart and especially
during these economically turbulent
times everyone's looking for a way to
feel more financially secure so if
you're still
needlessly throwing money every month at
high interest credit card debt it's time
you checked out upstart the
revolutionary
online lending platform that knows
you're more
than just a credit score and now is the
time to find out how low your upstart
rate can be to help pay off
high interest credit card debt unlike
other lenders upstart can reward you
based on your education and job history
in the form of a smarter rate but
you do not need a degree or a diploma to
apply though
upstart lets you skip going to the bank
because it's completely online
and they're offering loans from a
thousand to fifty thousand dollars so
you can consolidate your debt into one
easy fixed rate payment upstart makes it
fast and simple to check your rate and
since it's just a soft pull
it does not affect your credit score the
hard pull happens if you accept your
rate
and you proceed with your application
and the best part is if the loan is
approved and accepted most people are
getting their funds the very next
business day
over 400 000 people have used upstart to
pay off credit cards or meet their
financial goals
free yourself from the burden of high
interest credit card debt
and get back to using your money your
way with upstart
see why upstart has a 4.9 out of 5
rating on trustpilot in a hurry to
upstart.com
honeydew to find out how low your
upstart rate can be checking your rate
only takes a few minutes that's
upstart.com honeydew
now let's get back to the do y'all can i
ask you more personal questions i mean
you've been pretty goddamn open about it
you
waxed your [ __ ] you told us um yeah
won't be doing that for a while
have you how long has it been
like uh three two
three two months and have you had an
outbreak since no
so do do they are there is there any
predictable
like in the first year you get them more
often and they fade as it goes is there
any sort of predictability to
to it yeah it could because after the
first
i've really done my research now um but
after
so you build up antibodies to it so it's
like you built your body builds up
immunity to it so
so you won't get the flu symptoms the
next time
no okay and it's because your body's not
being exposed to it it's just it's in
your it's in your system
now and um so
yeah it's every year you're likely to
get less and less because it's like
less your body's more immune to it got
it and that's why
in this work group that's one healthy
thing girl was like the first year i
felt like i was having an outbreak every
day
and so i took the pill which is what i
take i take it every day so to
prevent it but i kind of felt like that
too i was like every day i was like is
this it
like you know like any feeling i'm like
is this it like
and um but i don't feel
i feel less stressed about it because
i'm not putting myself out there so even
if i have an outbreak it really affects
no one
my friend was like you're lucky you
don't get it on the mouth because you
know the cold sores are herpes
technically and i was like i'd much
rather have it on the mouth
but but isn't that isn't that simplex
one versus
genital which is two or am i wrong about
it you're right but you can also get one
on your genitals like if you go down on
someone with a gold sore they can get it
one on their genitals you know i didn't
this is embarrassing for me to even say
but it wasn't until later in my life
that i
didn't know that a girl could give me
herpes by giving me head yeah like i
didn't know
and then they said that's actually one
of the most common ways
is that she has herpes i guess on her
mouth or whatever
and then gives you oral sex you can get
it i was like huh
i did not i mean i did not know that
[ __ ]
well that's the thing because when you
think herpes you think of a girl
in a dumpster like you don't think of
someone just like a normal person
so there's no i wasn't educated either
that's it
there's the big thing and that's why i'm
glad you're talking about it because
people are uneducated about it i didn't
know that i had no i'm like wait she can
give me
she can get like i get it that she could
get it from me if i have herpes on my
dick
but i didn't know that i could get it
from her if she gives me a head and she
has it like
i met a girl one time too that was like
oh i got um
look this girl was this girl was
there was no shame to her game she was a
playboy that's the god oh my god i can't
believe this
she was like you but was actually a
playboy buddy this guy like you but she
was actually good at it
i can't believe this is this is a true
story and you just made me think of this
and i'm gonna tell you about this girl
so
back in the day i used to there was a
guy when i was a producer
um for this network he was a pa and i
moved up from a pa so i trained him i
knew this guy's dude was big into
ecstasy
all this [ __ ] like he'd be standing
there you'd be like i need you to take
this thing that he
he just bust a dance move like what are
you doing bro it was just coursing
through him
all the time no exercise oh yeah all day
long all the time
he getting his honda prelude he bumped
that club music at two in the afternoon
and just drive away and hear it going in
the distance
so i would go to their place to buy weed
well
they had a it was him and a few buddies
that rented a house and there was an
apartment complex very la you got a nice
backyard pool and everything is a
monster apartment complex that can look
right into your [ __ ]
and there was this hot ass blonde
very girl next door tv show girl next
door
um chick that would always come over and
she'd always come out
like jesus christ you come over and
party with us and
um she had a dog and a friend of mine
his roommate was moving out and he's
like man is there any chance you know
anybody looking for a place to rent
and is dog friendly and i was like as a
matter of fact i do because this girl
just said
so i connect these two and she moves
into his place well i would go over
there too he
ended up being a maryland guy go talk
orioles ravens whatever
and she was always so sweet and very
nice
but she was a playboy
model um and she's like i actually had
the raciest playboy
video that they remember they used to do
those playmate videos
no i'm not a 15 year old boy you didn't
know
but you wanted to be one of these girls
i know but you would have been in a
video i wasn't 15. i was in this is my
20s
but they used to do these videos of like
they would take the playmate of the
month or whatever and then do some
[ __ ] lingerie
softcore kind of thing with each one of
them yeah you'd have been one
so yeah i'm listening so she pops this
vhs in and we're like what the [ __ ] and
she's showing us this you know she's
getting
dude banging or whatever so it's just
straight porn then
it's but you don't see penetration you
don't see any of that stuff it's soft
and it wasn't really
they weren't you could tell was it was
it was all the moment before the moment
[ __ ]
you know what i'm saying so this chick
was an alcoholic too big time and she
was like i can't
she drank budweis she belched louder and
longer than any dude i ever met
i mean this is a like a girl next door
hugh hefner girl next door type girl and
she's like yeah and she had these like
autographed hockey sticks in her bedroom
and i'm like what are these all about
she's like oh
i've uh i [ __ ] a few of the mighty
ducks
the anaheim ducks i'm like huh then she
tells us
that she got chlamydia of the throat now
i had never
heard of that before i didn't know you
could get chlamydia
in the [ __ ] throat and she's like
yeah i
uh i sucked a guy's dick who had
chlamydia and
i'm like we're good we're good and i'm
i'm to your point of the hot chick and
the zoom thing
there wouldn't have been one dude that
would have said no to that girl and
if i didn't know what i knew i would
have i wouldn't have known enough to say
no
she was so [ __ ] dirty so dirty that i
had
that was a new one to me and to this day
chlamydia of the throat
[ __ ] haunts me haunts me well my
friend got his dick sucked in quarantine
and he got chlamydia
and he was like wait from getting a
[ __ ] yeah
look i'm 47. uh you're you can get
chlamydia from head
well because she probably had at the
throat and she probably passed it
i guess on yeah yeah and i was like god
you [ __ ] up damn i was like don't
[ __ ] lie to me he's like i didn't i
didn't and that's what's so crazy but
did he make out with her i figured you'd
get it that way too
oh [ __ ] yeah i don't know but you can
get rid of that right yeah that one gets
you can get rid of i remember friends in
high school had it
you know chlamydia yeah they would get
chlamydia and get rid of it
guys and girls would get it and get rid
of that one um
i think that's the frustrating part of
it this is one that stays
yeah like i had a friend get chlamydia
three times in a year
and i'm like meanwhile i'm just like
rocking this herpes like
[ __ ] scarlet letter on the puss and
it's like [ __ ]
i just feel like it's
i just feel like it's yeah and it sucks
because it's it's truly like
um you know you
he lied and it's like it sucks because
it's now it's like this thing i have and
it's the stigma i wear
or like you know have and it's
he lied so it's that's the that's the
worst like
it'd have been one thing if he was
genuinely like i didn't know i had it
went to the doctor and was like oh [ __ ]
i i have it you know
yeah but you knew and you even know the
[ __ ] girl you know who you
know the person that gave that [ __ ] to
you and and
three weeks after i called him i was
like did you get tested he was like no i
haven't gotten tested yet
i'm like you still haven't gotten tested
like you need to go to the [ __ ]
doctor
you need to take medication like you
need to figure out like how to prevent
this
but he doesn't need to get tested he
knows he has it because he
clearly had an outbreak when he gave it
to you he wouldn't
if you had another outbreak aren't you
gonna know it like
undoubtedly will you or maybe not i
don't know what i'm asking
um yeah i mean yeah you would know right
yeah but if you're dating a guy and
you're about to have sex
you would be able to say look we can't
do that right now yeah
exactly exactly and so he knew he
and he knew he was gonna go unprotected
as well he could have at least
put a [ __ ] condom on yeah
he's it's just like i'm sorry that that
is that's what that's the worst part of
it is that you were
you were lied to yeah yeah and i like
sent
knowing everything you could have just
said well i'll wait
yeah i'm not like dying you weren't
dying for that dick
exactly and that's what pisses me off
and then it's like now i just have this
thing and i it's just embarrassing but
it's also like it's such a
it doesn't matter like it's not a
disease or a disease i guess
it feels so weird to call it a disease
you know what i mean because it's like
do you get diagnosed with herpes or
do you go out and find it yeah did you
get in a bathroom at a [ __ ] sports
bar
it's it's like you know what i mean it's
like i gotta but it's hard to say it's
so worthwhile but it is something that
doesn't affect like
my work or um my friendships whereas
like
other diseases do you know at least
so in that sense i'm like
whatever like i need a break from dudes
anyway and
i don't know i've kind of just said that
i was like i've accepted i'm probably
gonna be alone so
now it's just like well at least i have
an excuse now i just have this weird
like
yeah scary it was just really scary at
first but now it's like
whatever so you did you've done the
online dating thing right
yeah are there are there sites or uh
stuff for people who have herpes or
something anything like yeah there are
which in the support group they're like
i know positive singles which is the app
sounds really dumb but you should
download positive singles
so that's the app it's called positive
singles yeah that's what people with
general herpes are called positive
singles if they're single
well you can choose which disease you
have
for real yeah so that's so aids
whatever's on there i think so i didn't
check because i don't have aids
you could've though yeah
get past that one uh there was a moment
though when i called because of my blood
test i was like
she's like oh it's irregular you have an
irregular you need to speak to the
doctor again i was like irregular
i knew i had herpes i was like i do have
hiv and she was like yes you have hiv
and i was like what
she's like oh i'm sorry uh hsv it's hsv
and i was like
no i was like oh yeah so for three
seconds i thought i had hiv three to
five seconds and i was like
and i was like read the [ __ ] chart
before you talk to me you know what i
mean
why do we got to have anything that's
even remotely close to hiv
yeah true right even remotely closely
why is it
why is there anything with an h and a v
but someone's like you should just tell
someone don't say you have herpes say
you have hsv
because that does sound a little less
like you know hpv hi vhs v but like
herpes is like that is
that's the that's every punch line you
know what i mean
it's like a punchline of i was really
recently watching inside amy schumer and
she has like this whole
episode about herpes that was like the
ongoing joke
and i was like does this [ __ ] even
[ __ ] have it like
just piss me it just does piss me off
and i used to use it as a punchline too
but it's like
now it's like [ __ ] you guys like you
know
that's my joke now because i [ __ ]
have it um
but but you jumped right into talking
about it you didn't
i think because it's just been on my
mind so much you know i haven't been
able to
but you're a comedian that's who we are
like yeah
there's no way it's not gonna literally
come out of you and be talked about
exactly that's the thing i wasn't
planning on talking about it and then i
was just like it's literally all i've
been able to think about
and i'm like [ __ ] it like here we go
i just think it's helpful honestly that
you
i know it sucks and i'm so sorry that
because
it yeah you could have gone into this
willingly
i mean you got lied to you got you got a
[ __ ] lie to
are there legal ramifications for [ __ ]
like that you said you mentioned a
lawyer
yeah there are you are there really
someone yeah what is it what do you do
you can just uh it's you can sue someone
for i forgot it is but it's just like
i forget what the correct term is but if
you give someone a disease that they
have to take care of and manage the rest
of their life
it's you i think it's up to like 15 20
000
i'm like i know this [ __ ] doesn't have
that and like i would have to get a
lawyer
and like go to court and do all i know
yeah i know
it's just like i hear it it's not worth
it and then i was like should i just
venmo charge him a thousand dollars from
a medication and be like pay this or
whatever my friend's like that's
extortion you cannot do that
no you can't be like you better pay me a
thousand or else have you heard from
this guy at all
nothing no you block him you i didn't
block him because i'm like
i don't care about him that much like
i'm like so disappointed but
i and also like i don't know i just i'm
because you know now we have this deep
connection uh no but i feel like
i i just didn't block him because i feel
like i blocked people who mentally like
bother me
and he i'm not i didn't like him like i
didn't love him you know
it was like a very we dated a pretty
short period so it's like
i was just so [ __ ] pissed and um
i don't really think like even when i
think about the herpes i don't even
think about him
yeah because i'm like he's never going
to be in my life like i'll never talk to
him again
or inside you again exactly well we'll
see
i don't know i made some bad decisions
yeah
i like guys come back eight or nine
times before i'm like uh-uh
and they're like yeah we're not there
anymore um well let me ask you this
because i ask everybody that comes on
for the first time um
advice you would give to your 16 year
old self oh man yeah wrap it up
um always always i don't know i feel
like
i didn't have sex when i was like 19
and i think i would just say like
i would not that i've had sex with a ton
of dudes but like
i really wish i had been more like
i really wish now i just had been more
selective
and i i think going forward it probably
will be but i think it's
i'll use it probably will be probably
will be it's only been a couple months
you know
you're the best
you know it's like not drinking you know
you go into it so hard you're like i'm
not gonna drink ever again then you're
like all right maybe holidays all right
really
good you know you're really sorry it's a
tuesday
so i think it would just be like don't
give guys so much [ __ ] credit cause
they're losers
not you know all these guys but it's
like i feel like i
i put so much of my worth into that for
so long and even till
you know this happened and i'm just like
what the [ __ ] am i doing like i'm better
than these people
and like i don't need this in my life
and i feel like i
i truly just put too much worth into it
so just like [ __ ]
dudes not actually you know
will you one more time promote
everything you want to promote please
yeah this was like quite this this
turned into full-on herpes
yeah um yeah i have a podcast called
don't tell mom if you want some more
herpes insight
just kidding we talk about other things
sometimes and uh
i yeah the epics half hour
yeah my instagram is sticky yours is
great
yeah yeah so right
well thank you thank you for coming on
and and seriously thank you for being so
open and so goddamn funny about
something that's
you know really tough to deal with so
thank you thanks for having me
you got it uh as always ryan sickler on
all social media ryan sickler.com we'll
talk to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you